for this cold calculated and Reckless
attack Connor Chapman handed a prison
sentence like no other
the 23 year old found guilty of
murdering Ellie Edwards ten minutes
before Christmas day will serve a
minimum of 48 years behind bars thought
to be the longest criminal life sentence
in this country you didn't care who else
would be killed
that's why you fired all of the bullets
at the group
I'm satisfied that you are a highly
dangerous man
and if you're ever released and
considering your dangerousness that
might never happen you will be on
license for the rest of your life
evidence throughout this four-week trial
was overwhelming Connor Chapman caught
driving a stolen Mercedes onto the pub
car park an hour before his attack 12
minutes after his brutal shooting he was
spotted ruffling his long hair and
dropping the gun as he walked towards
his friend's house and DNA covered on a
red glove he wore that night along with
a bullet casing found at the scene of
the murder
as Chapman was sentenced with this
Landmark punishment summer Valley's
family waved goodbye to the man who's
brought so much pain others shouted
scumbag but there was an overall sense
of relief inside the court that Justice
had been served the new things need to
change and we've made the start with
that and I think for 48 years
if you think of picking up a gun now you
should think twice about it Ellie's
murder last year was the fifth fatal
shooting in merseyside another ongoing
gang Feud which brought Terror to this
region streets and it was yet again this
weapon a scorpion submachine gun used in
combat which ended another life although
today was a success for this family
Christmas without Ellie will never be
the same a brother who says he's lost
everything a grandma who says she'll die
with a broken heart a father left
questioning what would have been of this
young woman's life into man Rashid Sky
News Liverpool